what president biden is calling a
full-scale wartime effort
to fight this pandemic and get the
country back to normal
on his first full day in the office the
president described a desperate
situation
likely to get worse before it gets
better he said
but he also laid out a very ambitious
agenda
including new executive actions on
vaccines and the economy
wishing is at the white house rija
what's the plan good morning to you
good morning to you gail and good
morning to everyone well today president
biden plans to sign
two new executive orders to provide
economic relief from the coven 19
pandemic
the first one will focus on providing
more financial assistance for food
amid a growing hunger crisis and the
second aims to help federal workers in
part by restoring collective bargaining
and worker protections that the trump
administration rescinded
the orders today will bring president
biden's total
in three days of executive orders and
actions to 29
help is on the way
the first wave of help is coming through
10 executive orders that president biden
signed
thursday he promised to do better than
his
predecessor but he reminded americans of
the reality
ahead we didn't get into this mess
overnight
it's going to take months for us to turn
things around
the president invoked the defense
production act compelling companies to
make supplies
everything from more syringes to ppe
part of mr biden's actions aimed to
increase testing and vaccinations
but he bristled when a reporter asked
him if as some experts have suggested
the promise of 100 million vaccines in
100 days
is too low
far higher that's basically where the
u.s is right now
when i announced that you all said it's
not possible come on give me a break
back in the briefing room over two
months after his last appearance
dr anthony fauci who returned as
president biden's
chief medical advisor one of the things
that we're going to do
is to be completely transparent open
and honest if things go wrong not point
fingers but to correct them fauci said
he already
feels the difference of working under a
president who
fully embraces science the idea
that you can get up here and talk about
what you know
what the evidence what the science is
and know that's it
let the science speak it is somewhat of
a liberating feeling
some state officials tell cbs news the
federal government has already reached
out more in the past 36
hours including from fema offering to
set up and staff
mass vaccination sites at the same time
the president is trying to convince
congress to pass a 1.9
trillion dollar rescue package including
funding for those centers nationwide
he feels that package is designed for
bipartisan
support but so far the moderate
republicans needed to seal the deal
say it's too pricey yesterday senator
susan collins of maine joined her
colleague senators mitt romney and lisa
murkowski
and saying it's hard to imagine
supporting such a big package
when they just passed a 900 billion plan
at the end of last year
anthony we just thank you